Thank you.
Thank you, everyone.
Well, there's one thing I've learned working
with my team that I would like to share and
that I will never forget is that we know that
writing fast applications makes our users
and our customers happy.
So, who doesn't want to write fast code?
Raise your hand.
Naw.
That's interesting.
So, before we start, I have a couple of questions
that I need to ask.
And then I'll see what the Internet tells
us.
So, the first question is, if you go on your
favorite web browser and your favorite search
engine and you type "Is JavaScript fast?
How fast is JavaScript?"
Probably get something like this that says,
and I'm just quoting," Under the right circumstances
it is very fast.
Actually, as fast as C."
If you search again, another result would
be, "Why is it so fast?
It is because as soon as you understand event
loop and how it processes requests, you realize
it's so fast."
You start to see a pattern, because fast is
because it's fast.
And you keep going on and you get stuff like,
"How can it be so fast since it's a single
thread?"
And the answer, like in this example is because
it's lightweight.
We keep going and then you find this interesting
question."
How fast is it compared to Java?"
Well, because most recruiters think that Java
and JavaScript is the same thing, which is
kind of interesting.
So, if you look around on the Internet, you
see JS is and shines when it comes to a huge
amount of short connections.
And finally, I could be all day showing Google
results.
But what does it make faster than Java?
Well, and the answer is because the sync ecosystem
is more than 50,000 modules written in asynchronous
style.
It's kind of a strange answer to the question.
But giving all these questions, we need to
ask, do we trust the Internet?
Like the Internet is full of stories, and
like some Game of Thrones characters said
a few weeks ago, stories connect people.
However, stories are not exact science.
And above all, they should not drive us as
a software engineer.
So, my interpretation is, do I trust the Internet?
No.
I don't.
And why?
Because I am a software engineer, as you can
if you don't know who invented who coined
term you can go in our exhibition hall and
there's an explanation there who did it.
And you see that if you look on the dictionary
for software engineering, it says engineer
is the application of science and mathematics
by which the properties of matter and the
sources of energy and nature are made useful
to people.
So, as a software engineer, we should apply
science and mathematics to solve our problems.
So, going back to the question, is JavaScript
fast?
We need we must be able to reproduce a problem.
We must be able to explain the results.
And reproduce the results.
So, I think the right answer is, is JavaScript
fast?
I don't know.
From these results, it's not clear.
So, starting now with the main topic.
Like when I was planning the talk, I needed
a title.
So, I ended up with so things I learned make
the fastest JavaScript server runtime in the
world.
I carefully decided to pick the word "Server."
Going to Wikipedia for a definition, a server
is a computer in the network of users that
is used to provide services to other computers
in the network.
So, what I'm about to tell you is not about
command line applications or lambdas.
It's about long running processes.
So, we need to also define what is fast.
So, because when I say fast, I don't mean
I'm fast because I put my server on a race
car and the car running around.
No.
What I mean by fast is we need to obtain a
common set of metrics.
And for this, I'm using what the site reliability
engineering has found out.
So, if don't know anything about site reliability
engineering, there's this interesting link
with nice books from Google.
And Google has one of the biggest teams on
SRE.
And SRE has identified five golden signals.
So, golden signals are critical to the monitoring
teams to monitor their systems and identify
problems before they become really big problems.
So, there are many metrics to monitor.
But this team this team this SRE team showed
that rate errors and latency, saturation utilization
contain virtually everything you need to know
about what's going on and where.
Getting the signals is quite challenging and
relies on a lot of the tools and services
you have at your disposal.
But for now, I'm just considering rate as
in request per second.
Errors like in errors per second, of course.
And latency as in like response time including
waiting and queuing.
So, focusing on wait, errors and latency.
I'm focusing on the software.
I'm not focusing on the hardware or in the
operating system.
So, a typical server application has a wellset
wellknown set of characteristics.
We need to know how the application behaves
and only once we understand that, we can talk
about it.
So, what is a server application?
So, my definition of server application is
a long running process that should be deployed
on a cloud or in bare metal.
And it should be attached to a fast network.
Otherwise the network becomes your bottleneck.
And, of course, should have enough CPU and
memory.
So, your application is not strained by your
hardware.
So, a longrunning process has different characteristics
from a shortrunning process, of course.
So, in a longrunning process, the startup
and warming up is not really relevant in the
fullspan life cycle of the server because
it's a very tiny moment.
Again, this isn't true if you're talking about
web applications on your browser.
Because you want to be as fast as possible
because that's what's drives the happiness
of your users.
So, now we need to define our two major things.
Our two benchmark things.
Most Internet articles will tell you how fast
something is.
But most of the time when you read the whole
article, you see some graphs, really nice
graphs.
But the information about how the tests will
perform and how the results were obtained
is needed.
From an engineering perspective, this is incorrect.
We should be able to reproduce the test and
the results.
In a lab that gives you more or less exactly
the same results of course.
On top of that, the experiment was we need
to confirm that the results are not biased.
So, when I write a benchmark, I don't want
to make it be my friend and enemy of the others.
It needs to be fair.
And writing benchmarks, of course, is hard.
Because first every benchmark you write will
never represent a real-world use case.
It's always like a tiny subset that doesn't
really represent your application.
So, you need to get into conclusions from
just looking at the tiny bit of your life
cycle.
So, getting peers to review your code can
be really hard to find.
And getting peers to that are willing to review
what you wrote is even harder.
So, what I'm trying to tell is that benchmarking
is hard.
And, however, there is a very popular benchmark
out there that is called the tech and power
frameworks benchmark.
Why is this benchmark so interesting to me?
Well, to me it's like taking power.
A benchmark shows you the true nature of open
source.
It has more than 500 contributors.
So, more than 500 different people have contributed
to tests and reviewed the tests.
There are more than 3,000 merged pull requests.
So, lots of people spend time reviewing or
adding new tests to the framework.
And they already have more than 10,000 commits.
So, it shows that it's kind of a big project.
It's not something that someone just planned
in the weekend.
Oh, I want to check on my framework, how it
works.
No, it's something that has been growing steadily
for the last couple of years.
And it already tests more than 630 different
frameworks.
And these frameworks are written in different
languages.
So, this makes my life easier because I don't
need to invent my own benchmark.
I don't need to explain it.
I can just use it to prove what I want to
say.
So, if you want to have the link, this is
like their GitHub repo.
And from the GitHub repo you can get to the
main website, of course.
And as I said, there are like 630 different
frameworks.
So, if I would try to print on the screen
how it looks right now, well, it wouldn't
fit on the screen.
So, what I did, I just rotated my screen.
I took a screenshot.
And don't worry about the size.
It's not really relevant.
What I'm trying to say is that there are lots
of frameworks that are already being tested.
And the quick question I want to ask the audience
is, like, can you spot the best result for
the JavaScript framework on this graph?
So, probably you cannot because it's very
small.
So, I have here a helper.
You'll find that as shocking as it can be,
the first entry for JavaScript ranks at number
89.
Which performs at about 22.7% of the performance
of the best result.
So, if you look at this, and think, well,
we all have this idea that JavaScript is fast,
but results prove things wrong.
That it's not as fast as we think it is.
So, what we need to do is that we need to
look under the hood.
So, before we can do any optimization, we
need to understand what's going on.
And we shouldn't jump into conclusions and
start tweaking the code of the benchmark.
Because otherwise we are just yak shaving.
And you're not really looking into the problem.
You're just trying to mitigate what could
be the cause.
So, instead of this, we need to take a scientific
approach.
And if you haven't learned anything about
profiling in other applications, I would recommend
for you to look at the tutorial on the NodeJS
website on profiling.
So, just to give you like in a nutshell the
information from the from this tutorial.
That if you look at one of the tests of the
benchmark, which is a very simple return,
hello world string from an HTTP server.
The best result that you could that you saw
on the benchmark was implemented like this.
So, it uses the cluster module.
The cluster module will fork the node process
for the number of CPUs that the environment
has.
And then it uses the express server to set
the content type and send the response.
Okay.
Probably the express is not the most performant
library out there.
But this is just for illustration.
So, once we do this and we do profiling, we
get a flame graph.
So, flame graphs are really interesting too
when we're talking about performance because
they give you a visual explanation on where
your CPU time is spent.
The width of the bars or the coloring doesn't
really matter.
The coloring is just to give it make it nice
and it's called flame graphs because usually
we paint it from red to yellow like a flame.
But what is important to notice is that as
you go from bottom up, you see where the code
is spending most time on your CPU.
So, if you observe this, you basically what
the flame graph is telling you is that there
is a very tiny piece on the top where JavaScript
code is being spent on.
And then there's lots of time where it's spent
on native.
And native means the Node bindings, V8 will
leave for the sync IO and also for the event
loop.
So, once we start trying to optimize this,
the code, we end up like trying to optimize
just the tip of the iceberg.
You cannot optimize everything.
Because most of the time and if I would go
back most of the time here is spent on native
code.
So, you're just optimizing the tip of the
iceberg.
So, this makes you think, right?
This is interesting.
What can we do about this?
If you ask yourself, what is the first thing
that comes on your mind when I say, JavaScript
engine?
Most of you will say V8.
So, if you look at the mission statement of
the V8 project, it reads something like speed
up real world performance for more than JavaScript
and enable developers to build a faster future
web.
So, performance on V8 is great.
But there are more engines out there.
So, if you look at the table, not an authority
on JavaScript engines.
Just lists the compatibility of ES6 across
many.
There you can see engines like ChakraCore,
SpiderMonkey, Safari.
And there was a new one added last year, crowdjs.
So, what my experiment was all about is that,
well, I should try other engines.
Because if most of the CPU is spent on native,
probably I should look into engines that handle
this JavaScript runtime in a different way.
So, I decided to look into rawjs.
So, raw JS is an extension of the Java machine
that supports more languages and execution
models.
So, the project includes a new hey performance
compiler called Raw because as you know the
most difficult thing in computer science and
science is naming things.
You all it also Graal because it is interesting.
And the objective of Graal is to improve the
performance of the machine on any language.
And another goal is to allow free form mixing
of any programming language in a single program.
So, it allows you to do polyglot programming.
So, on the same program you can use Java,
Scala, Ruby, Rust, C++.
And what's interesting about this is that
because it's a new project and it's all up
to date, they offer a modern JavaScript runtime
based on ES2019, ES2020, which isn't released
yet but they already implemented most of the
features.
And the ultimate goal is a very fast server.
But I don't want to change my programming
language.
I want to stay on JavaScript.
So, if I look at the definition of rawjs on
their website, their goals are to execute
JavaScript code with the best possible performance.
They have full support for the latest ES specification.
And the fast interoperability with all the
languages on either on the JVM or the language
supported by Graal like Ruby, Python and R.
There is research around this because this
project, although it was open sourced last
year, it's been running for more than eight
years behind closed doors.
It's just been opened now because now they
feel that it's like in a real stable mature
project.
So, the people working and researching on
this have already shown that the engine is
slightly better or on par with V8 for just
pure language benchmarks.
And you can read more about the paper there.
So, and although you can even run like unmodified
Node applications on it because it just allows
you to just replace V8 from Node, I need to
formulate a hypothesis.
What if we create a project that I would call
agnostic for X that first will replace V8
with a project.
Second, will replace the Eclipse vortex.
Will replace the V8 with a Graal compiler.
Will not have Node bindings.
It will have text definitions.
This will be discarded at runtime.
The code that you don't run is the best code,
it's the fastest.
You don't need to run it.
And offer a basic JS and loader.
And basic compatibility and allows you to
develop and profile the application with the
tools you already know like the Chrome DevTools.
So, if we were going to implement the previous
example that I showed with Node and express
using this new style, this is how the old
express code would look like.
I guess it's not that hard to understand what's
happening here.
The important thing here to notice is that
the library I chose, vortex, by default uses
all the available cores on your machine so
you don't need to use a cluster module to
do forks.
This is all handled behind the scenes for
you.
And Vortex provides us an optimized sync IO
build on to have of an open source project
used by big names like Google, Twitter, Netflix
just to name a few.
If you want to test this, first thing, well,
you need to install a very simple application
called ES4XPM short for project manager.
We cannot run Node directly.
Need to run through ES first.
If I show you, this is how it looks.
If I create a project.
I can make it like with a new module syntax.
And I recorded this so because I'm afraid
that I wouldn't have enough time.
So, just have a couple of dependencies.
This is pure npm stuff.
I just use Vortex and web because I want to
do a web application.
So, I create and you can even do like the
ES6 modules.
I can say, okay.
My home page is a function that I will export
that will just say, hello.
Hello from Vortex Plus ES4X.
And, of course, now I need to bootstrap a
server.
I get my index, which is like my main application.
And again, just import some code from the
vortex library.
I now import my route from the module I just
created.
Route.
And now I just bootstrap the bootstrap my
application.
So, I create the router.
It's kind of the same idea as the express
server.
So, I now create the router a route on home.
And I just paste my callback.
And now I create the server.
I specify who will handle my server request.
Who will be my router?
And I start listening on port 8080.
Same hello message.
So, I'm running.
So, now I can just install starting to make
npm and doesn't really matter.
There are a couple of utilities.
I can quickly get all of my application running
on VSCode.
You can see it's already bugging.
I can put a break point.
And if I put a break point and now make an
HTTP request, you see that the request there
is stopped.
And what's interesting here to see is that
due to the nature of GraalVM, you can see
on the debugger, the code from the Java side
and the code that you wrote.
Everything is optimized.
So, the expectation is that once you write
code in this way, your user code plus your
runtime plus your interop plus your engine
plus your IO libraries plus the whole world
that runs your application.
In this case, the Graal JDK.
It will all be optimized by Graal.
Not just the script itself.
Not just optimizing the tip of the iceberg,
you're optimizing everything.
To test it, I submitted to the tech and power
implementation using this project.
It was reviewed and got accepted and this
is how things are.
This is like the CI builds.
You see now ES4X is ranking on number five
which brings JavaScript from number 86 if
I'm not mistaken to number five in simple
database query test that gets results.
And ranked number six when doing multiple
queries.
So, you see the parallel loading and testing.
So, if I have to compare now this experiment
with all the frameworks that were already
on the benchmark, this is how it compares.
So, when working with JSON we see that the
results give you like two times better results
than the previous best result.
When going on a post base, doing one query,
it's three and a halftimes better.
But if you have to be fair, testing for the
best previous one running on Postpress, it's
six times better doing multiple queries.
There's lots of concurrency going on.
It's still two and a halftimes better than
the previous one.
And doing data updates where the query is
really the issue, it's like five times better
than the previous one.
To put this in numbers if you think about
request response, you see that IO is better,
of course.
I'm not talking about a very small improvement,
tiny improvements.
I'm talking about huge numbers.
So, the final tip is that optimization is
like a neverending job.
So, for example, we could get better results
if we used an enterprise edition of Graal
instead of the open source edition.
That gives you like 20% better performance.
And because it's optimization, it's a neverending
job.
You need to rinse and repeat and go just like
that.
So, the key points I want to give is that
there's nothing wrong with JavaScript.
JavaScript can be fast.
And probably you don't need to switch to Go,
Rust, whatever, because you're having performance
issues.
You can still if you dare to experiment, you
can still remain on JavaScript.
So, if you want to learn more you can.
Either find me on Twitter, GitHub, the source
code forum on GitHub.
And if there are any questions, you can catch
me later.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]